tell your men to wear white goodness
look at us
we are now raising funds to build houses
for those who have been homeless due to
natural disasters in Afghanistan Syria
and Pakistan please donate whatever you
can may Allah build you guys at home for
helping and enabling them to have a
house
brothers and sisters and dear friends
this video I came across about three
weeks to about a month ago and I was
really really alhamdulillah like amazed
that this pastor this priest who lives
in South Africa is good you said priest
otherwise we would have had to go on a
tangent about pasta spaghetti jokes and
then it would have taken long to come
back yeah I don't like pasta what but I
like this pasta okay so brothers and
sisters this is a video of this man not
only himself he has a dream which we're
going to listen to ourselves and just
see how this dream leads to him and not
only him but his whole congregation to
Islam then we're going to come to maybe
a few contentions someone might have and
say well hold on a second you know
there's a lot of these Christian videos
who come and say yo you know this person
saw Jesus and he was like yes this is
the truth and whatever whatever I'm not
going to tell you why this is different
to that completely we're gonna find out
about here's the video of his journey
and how an entire church in South Africa
comes to Islam through a dream and
obviously with the guidance let's watch
it
[Music]
thank you
so I've been a priest for 15 years
of South Africa it's got about 100 000
followers until I had a dream I was
sleeping
and I'm hearing this voice I was
sleeping in the chair he says
then I hate this voice since tell your
men
to wear white
[Music]
he came again and again and the last
time this voice became aggressive
and I went there and I told them
you know how how Allah made it easy
they just accept it
all of them then when the next meeting
came on the next congregation everyone
was wearing it white gorgeous and all
those things
three months ago I met in the church and
they were supporting what I was saying
they were also saying those thousand
voices say one giving me
we were happy and that's all Muslim
Brothers coming I said I've been waiting
for you I've been waiting for you I had
a dream
you'll come here
[Music]
when they told me you are going to hike
me
[Music]
and when the day came they say you are
living I said living away
you must be shocked this is not heaven
it can't happen
to me like when I hear this when I see
this like obviously we know that for
Allah for him all things are possible
one thing you need to understand because
a lot of people when we're in the dawah
we wouldn't talk to atheists here and
people who are arrogant stubborn you
need to stop looking at me when you're
saying arrogance you know evil scums
vile creatures yeah you know when we
speak to them and give them dawah
because they're so hard-headed we think
everybody is like them bro I've been to
Africa after Darwin Malawi I've been to
certain other countries I've been to
Brazil these people are under Federal so
what that means is bro you can speak to
them about something so simple what do
you mean innate disposition that meaning
that you are born to have the propensity
to know that God is one and is not a man
there's certain things I'm trying to say
so when you speak to these people and
say do you really believe God came to
earth like a man and ate like me and you
there's people like actually you know
what this doesn't make sense so this is
why when we look at this somebody might
be watching this and say hold on a sec I
feel a dream he comes to Islam and then
it's called congregation really that
easy yes that easy why number one if
Allah wills it is possible number two it
shows your brother and sisters how
genuine when you watch this video
compared to the fake Christian videos
who have these people who are not even
Muslim in the first place so these
Iranians who you know or these Armenians
yeah okay who are enemies of Islam yeah
you know I was he was never a Muslim he
was never a Muslim and you know the
person who is telling the story is fake
his dream is fake the production is fake
the people who are filming is fake
everything is fake you know it it's so
clearly orchestrated with this one bro
you can see how genuine he is you can
see his reaction when he comes there and
you can see that subhanallah the whole
congregation mustache from what I
gathered they accepted Islam a week
before the second congregation you know
usually we when we do tawa if a whole
church comes to Islam we don't have the
footage we get them to repeat the same
thing on camera just so people can see
that that their donations and what's
happening just to show the work you get
it so that's why they were wearing the
hijab
Etc because you mentioned you know how
come they were in hijab he said on the
second congregation they came again they
told him to wear it so in that aspect
bro you need to understand the people in
Africa and these countries they are easy
the tower is so simple bro when you go
there you will probably not be able to
give that one you know why because
you'll be thinking I need to use big
arguments you don't need to bro
so simple bro simple stuff you can use
one verse from the bible where jesus
praises the father and go I thought if
he's got who's he praising the people
like yeah that's right this is this is
actually quite interesting because I was
actually thinking about this and if you
look at us being here in the west
there's so many different levels of
propaganda and so much information that
we're actually exposed to yes more
information than young kids were exposed
to in say the 80s like a significant
amount yes like one comedian said child
can go home and watch any movie ever
made at the touch of a button you've got
so many different ideas so to to kind of
get through to these people and sift
through the propaganda and all that
information it takes time it's not that
old the argument the argument is weak no
and when you go to say Africa because oh
not just Africa but just villages in
general people that haven't been exposed
to the Western propaganda and the
technology they like you said because
they're upon the federal natural
disposition it's going to affect them
more the truth stands clear from
falsehood as we know from the Quran and
it's more apparent but apparent to who
somebody that's been constantly
brainwashed for the last 10 years we
know the LGBT is constantly focusing on
our children and you're seeing that on
WhatsApp and hearing their little books
you know talking about explicit material
and people being shocked and stuff like
that why are kids you know being
targeted because of course it's that
programming so these individuals very
simple people live in villages go and
get water from Wells come to school
learn language maths keep things very
simple so it did we were kind of
speaking off camera and I was like look
what if this this I mean if we heard a
Christian do this and say I can't I I
had a dream sorry he was a Muslim and he
goes to his Masjid and he says I had a
dream about Jesus about Krishna firstly
I mean it wouldn't be a shock if a
Muslim had a dream about Jesus or
something along those lines because we
accept Jesus as well you know Christians
reject the prophet Jews respect uh
reject Jesus and the prophet we accept
both Moses and Jesus as well but what
was the point that you were making that
if a Muslim who became a mortadia and
claimed that he saw a dream attracting
Christianity how would that pan out well
the thing is that let's let's put into
perspective here have you ever seen an
entire Congregation of Muslims in a
Masjid coming to Christianity never ever
no no you know why because even one guy
if a guy coming says I saw Jesus in my
dream and he said he's good yeah okay
you know why because it's not matter
about a dream it's a matter of what is
tawheed what is reality which is what
any person you go to Bob a little child
you go to his child and say God is a man
he'll be like I was a little kid that
little girl she's like this doesn't make
sense so this is the truth because it's
the truth p it's not to me it's not
fathomable that oh an entire church
because all he had to do is go and say
hold on all this time we've been
worshiping this and believing this
Spider-Man yeah but if you think about
it that's that can't be true it's not
going to take bro it's not going to be
like oh my gosh I need a Miracles come
back actually yeah why have we been
believing this all this time when you go
to a church for go to a mosque and
somebody comes and says well why I saw
Jesus in my dream and he said he's good
that's the problem you saw shaytan um
simple as that because you know why you
are you want us to believe that the one
who created the heavens and the Earth
became a man like me and you came out
the private part of a woman are you are
you for real this is this is actually
interesting are you for real this is the
bro let me tell you something the
biggest enemy to Christianity is
Christianity yeah bro the Trinity is the
biggest factor which you see have you
ever seen in history millions of Muslims
live in their faith never this is
interesting but you see it you see it
today in the west millions of people
this shows that it is falsehood it's
impossible we know in Islam there's some
people that leave Islam yeah not in the
millions no way but this will show its
false wow how false it is not in the
millions because if it's a True Religion
bro it would withstand Islam has been
the most attacked religion vilified
religion billions half a billion pounds
spent by the FBI CIA yeah half a billion
pounds to vilify Muslims and Islam is
still the fastest Grand religion all
these ex-muslims and these atheists and
these mortalities crowns spent the last
decade Islam is intolerant Islam says
this about women Islam's capital
punishment and I'm proud of it and all
this kind of stuff and guess what people
are coming to Islam because it's
intolerant
oh yeah with with context of course no
it was a context with what you said yeah
yeah we're proud of it yeah so what's
what's interesting is that if if you've
got a um Muslim that that leaves Islam
yeah he goes to the congregation what
you're now doing is you're taking the
Islamic concept of God and then if
you're going to say Christian you're now
weakening that God you're saying that
God needs a blood sacrifice God needs to
calm down God needs to do this but when
a Christian is presented with Islam
you're upgrading your understanding of
God by saying he's a man God needs to
say you needed God doesn't need to do
anything exactly God is
none like him
he does not beget noisy begotten so
Islam is actually an upgrade because I
was thinking that you know dream and we
wouldn't accept that from others but
when it comes to Islam it's more
appealing to one's innate disposition
why because it makes sense it puts God
where he deserves to be put which is is
above anything anybody can ever imagine
I'm just for the last you know couple of
days I've been reading about you know
the stories of Hindu gods and honestly
reading that strengthens my Iman reading
that has actually made my man stronger
because the gods are are weak in one
aspect they have to calm down if they
come down you know then they're weak
they require help if they're up you know
whether it's what happens is they
require little godlings to do their work
because they they don't know what's
going on so they're Limited in in any
way you can imagine and I don't know how
somebody lives like that to be honest
living in a way that you you believe the
one that you're praying to is limited uh
that I think ties in world with what I
mean I'm not sure what you're saying is
that you had to see ugly to know what
beautiful is that's what it is
wise words from a wise man the man with
a plan if you can't nobody can till next
time brother sisters
if you guys enjoy our reaction videos
please recommend more inshallah and we
will try to benefit you guys until next
time brother sisters
[Music]
that's good